during Black History Month we're
highlighting remarkable community
members and this morning our Laura
negretti caught up with one woman's
effort to help people pay for their
medical supplies
wheelchairs patient care lifts medical
supplies just some of the various items
that Rosalind Jamerson has been
providing for the community free of
charge for nearly two decades we step in
to help those that are facing temporary
hardships a medical Devastation and so
that's what it's about whether it's
equipment food even notary services
Jamerson steps in especially for seniors
diapers bed pads whatever I needed
Iberia Brown Hodge has leaned on Roslyn
for the past seven years more than
friendship now it's just like a she's my
sister while I was there Amador medical
came to pick up a wheelchair yeah
other medical and hospice facilities
donate to and depend on medtime for
patients the non-profit came from
jamerson's own experiences her husband a
paramedic firefighter injured on the job
passed away while she had the fire
department support through his care
others aren't so lucky so I thought
about helping other people
because I am the people I was the people
so I know the struggle she supported the
effort with her own pension and through
donations ever since
she is really a pillar in a community
she helps out everyone Fredericks helps
as a grant writer I just walked in and
saw that
just about everything was donation based
especially the food items I saw a line
of people outside with their needs being
met Jameson struggled to make rent to
the current facility they need to move
at the end of February while medtime
will be moving out of this location
that's not stopping Rosalind she is
actively looking for a warehouse space
and is open to suggestions in Las Vegas
Lauren negretti 8 News Now entirely
remarkable woman Jamerson gets about 30
calls a day for assistance she's still
taking them a GoFundMe has been set up
to help with expenses for the move and
to establish a new location you can find
all that information at 8newsnow.com 6